-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night." We hope
you're all doing well tonight
and now let's get to the news.
House minority leader Kevin
McCarthy yesterday criticized
Russian President Vladimir Putin
and said,
"I think Putin is evil.
I think he's a dictator."
Added McCarthy, "That said,
I'd obviously still vote for him
in 2024."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden signed
an executive order yesterday
on cryptocurrency.
The order specifies that it can
no longer be
your entire personality.
"Yo, you pimps talkin' crypto?"
[ Laughter ]
According to newly released
documents,
former president Trump
refinanced Trump Tower
last month and took out
a $100 million loan.
It turns out the guy
he usually asks for money
is pretty busy right now.
[ Laughter ]
During a visit yesterday to
the Ukrainian Cultural Center
in London, Britain's Prince
William said that the ongoing
Russian invasion of Ukraine
makes him feel "useless."
Really?
You'd think British royalty
would be used to that by now.
[ Laughter ]
Former Trump White House senior
adviser Stephen Miller revealed
in a new legal filing
that he is still on
his parents' T-Mobile
family plan.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, man that is embarrassing.
They're on T-Mobile?
[ Laughter ]
Nintendo announced yesterday
that it will postpone
the release of a new war game
in light of recent world news,
and due to gas prices,
the new "Mario Kart."
[ Laughter ]
The assistant principal at an
elementary school in Mississippi
was fired last week after
he read the children's book
"I Need a New Butt"
to a second grade class,
following complaints from
parents that he used words like
"butt" and "fart," or as they
call it, critical race theory.
[ Laughter ]
The dating app Tinder announced
yesterday that users will now
be able to run background checks
on potential dates.
Although, wasn't everyone
already checking the background?
"Alright, she's cute,
but what's going on behind her?
Is that a monster energy drink?"
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, and looks like --
Yeah, that's a Chihuahua.
I'm swiping left!"
[ Laughter ]
Tiger Woods was inducted into
the Golf Hall of Fame yesterday
in Florida,
but he still hasn't heard back
from the Driving Hall of Fame.
[ Laughter, crowd ohhs ]
There's still time.
He just hasn't heard.
And finally, in a new interview,
a Virginia couple claimed that
in their over-30-year marriage,
they have never had
a single argument.
And if you want to know
what their secret is --
lying in interviews.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.